Jake: 干嘛嘞
Jake: What are you doing?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: I don't know.
Jake: 不知道
Jake: Don't know.
Jake: 好迷惑
Lucia: 可以啊这个是他是一整盒
Lucia: Yeah, this is a whole box.
Lucia: 一大盒对嗯
Lucia: A big box, right, yeah.
其他人：番茄每个人200克
Others: 200 grams of tomatoes per person.
Lucia: 对对也行
Lucia: Yes, yes, that's fine too.
Lucia: 而且如果大家想吃也可以挖出来挖
Lucia: And if everyone wants to eat, they can scoop it out.
Tasha: 我们就开始送3杯了
Tasha: We'll start giving out 3 cups.
Lucia: 我投票投票加入你的这个酸奶team
Lucia: I'm voting to join your yogurt team.
Lucia: 那这个就两三个人的量
Lucia: This amount is for two or three people.
其他人：因为它比较酸
Others: Because it's quite sour.
其他人：它是纯酸奶那么
Others: It's pure yogurt, so...
Alice: 你能喝纯酸奶吗
Alice: Can you drink pure yogurt?
Jake: 豆汁
Jake: Douzhi
Katrina:  啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Ah hahaha
Tasha: 没有我只是看到了
Tasha: No, I just saw it.
Katrina:  你你喝过豆汁没
Katrina: Have you ever drunk Douzhi?
Jake: 我喝过啊
Jake: I've had it.
Lucia: 啊我没喝过啊
Lucia: Ah, I've never had it.
Jake: 哪哪一款
Jake: Which kind?
Jake: 哈哈哈多少钱啊
Jake: Hahaha, how much is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 八块八
Tasha: 8.8 bucks.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one.
Lucia: 怎么如此热情哈哈
Lucia: Why so enthusiastic, haha.
Lucia: 所以它好喝吗
Lucia: So, is it tasty?
Shure:  看杨老板累的
Shure: Look how tired Jake is.
Shure:  给杨老板
Shure: Give it to Jake.
Lucia: 虽然说我在这上了好几年学
Lucia: Even though I've been studying here for years.
Katrina:  杨老板要喝豆汁
Katrina: Jake wants to drink Douzhi.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 行行行真的真的
Jake: Alright, alright, really, really.
Jake: 补补补补
Jake: Replenish, replenish, replenish.
Jake: 金币我去
Jake: Gold coins, I'm going.
Jake: 一个10块钱够了啊
Jake: One for 10 bucks is enough.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  一共3新币啊
Shure: It's 3 new dollars in total.
Jake: 我知道就是大概一个10新币
Jake: I know, it's about 10 new dollars.
Alice: 一个10新币
Alice: One for 10 new dollars.
Shure:  就是在在在新加坡的
Shure: Just like in Singapore.
Alice: 真的假的
Alice: Really?
Jake: 对在我在我家门口的那个商场里边
Jake: Yes, in the mall near my house.
Lucia: 你们不是靠海吗
Lucia: Aren't you guys near the sea?
Lucia: 怎么还这么贵
Lucia: Why is it still so expensive?
Jake: 我不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 他就是这个价啊
Jake: That's just the price.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake: 一个10新币
Jake: One is 10 SGD.
Shure:  快给杨老板补补
Shure: Quick, someone help Jake out.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  3新币咱可劲吃
Shure: We can eat for 3 SGD.
Jake: 这多少个
Jake: How many is that?
Lucia: 所有的三新币吗
Lucia: All for 3 SGD?
Jake: 这几个呀几个呀一二
Jake: How many, how many, one, two...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure:  10个左右大概
Shure: About 10, roughly.
Jake: 10个100新币
Jake: 10 for 100 SGD.
Jake: 500块钱你花了3
Jake: 500 RMB, you spent 3.
Jake: 你花了3新币
Jake: You spent 3 SGD.
Shure:  3新币
Shure: 3 SGD.
Lucia: 一共三星币
Lucia: Altogether 3 SGD.
Shure:  一共3新币
Shure: Altogether 3 SGD.
Jake: 呵呵是我是
Jake: Haha, it's me.
Shure:  19块9啊 18块9是吧
Shure: 19.9, 18.9, right?
Alice: 我马上就要拆开这个
Alice: I'm about to open this.
Shure:  3新币差不多
Shure: 3 SGD is about right.
Jake: 是是是你这大
Jake: Yes, yes, you are...
Jake: 你这哈哈哈
Jake: You are hahaha.
Jake: 中国我当500多了
Jake: In China, I could have gotten over 500.
Jake: 哈哈哈虚报虚报
Jake: Hahaha, exaggerated, exaggerated.
Jake: 这个还是能感觉出来的
Jake: You can still feel it.
Katrina:  这个还是能感觉出来
Katrina: You can still feel it.
Jake: 呵呵这in w的这个
Jake: Haha, it's in the W section.
Katrina:  面包在哪来着
Katrina: Where's the bread?
Katrina:  面包番茄酱
Katrina: Bread with tomato sauce.
Shure:  面包
Shure: Bread.
Katrina:  搞奶酪吗
Katrina: Cheese?
Katrina:  还是搞果酱
Katrina: Or jam?
Shure:  啊蒜还有啊
Shure: Ah, there's still garlic.
Shure:  咱们昨天买的那个蒜还有啊有啊
Shure: The garlic we bought yesterday, there's still some.
Jake: 不好意思
Jake: Sorry.
Katrina:  123我们6个人是不是拿两袋啊
Katrina: 123, there are 6 of us, should we get two bags?
Jake: 好啊
Jake: Sure.
Shure:  没有辣的了
Shure: There's no spicy one left.
Katrina:  两袋搞一点什么呢
Katrina: What should we get with two bags?
Katrina:  番茄酱在哪
Katrina: Where's the ketchup?
Katrina:  你们刚有看见吗
Katrina: Did you guys see it?
Alice: 能看英国干巴老头吗
Alice: Can we see that dry old British guy?
Alice: 又做他的干巴lunch哈哈
Alice: He's making his dry lunch again, haha.
Katrina:  其实他那种果酱也很好吃
Katrina: Actually, his jam is really good too.
Katrina:  就是他那个切的面包邦硬你知道吗
Katrina: But his sliced bread is super hard, you know?
Alice: 梆硬然后
Alice: Super hard and then...
Katrina:  他们说吃这个吗
Katrina: Do they eat this?
Katrina:  英国人
Katrina: The British?
Alice: 然后搞点那个干巴黄油
Alice: And then add some of that dry butter.
Katrina:  番茄酱你知道在哪吗
Katrina: Do you know where the ketchup is?
Katrina:  番茄酱
Katrina: Ketchup.
Shure:  感觉OK
Shure: Seems OK.
Shure:  需要再拿番茄酱
Shure: We need more ketchup.
Shure:  番茄酱
Shure: Ketchup.
Shure:  杨老板累了
Shure: Jake is tired.
Jake: 一般啊
Jake: Just a bit.
Alice: 你这边还有时间吗
Alice: Do you still have time?
Jake: 有吧我觉得还有40分钟左右
Jake: I think we have about 40 minutes left.
Alice: 30G了
Alice: It's 30G now.
Lucia: 哎帝王蟹腿
Lucia: Oh, king crab legs.
Jake: 差不多在这了是吧
Jake: It's almost here, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 肢解了放这了
Jake: Disassembled and put here.
Lucia: 对上次逛了时候还是先火的
Lucia: Yeah, last time we shopped it was hot.
Lucia: 这次已经变成冷藏的
Lucia: Now it's refrigerated.
Lucia: AI记者哈哈
Lucia: AI reporter, haha.
Katrina:  油油拿了是吧
Katrina: Did you get the oil?
Shure:  油有家里有油
Shure: We have oil at home.
Katrina:  那就OK了
Katrina: Then it's OK.
Shure:  走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina:  够了
Katrina: Enough.
Shure:  车子都放不下了
Shure: The car can't fit everything.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Shure:  老板的眼神感觉
Shure: The boss's look...
Jake: 哈哈哈今天只有一车还行
Jake: Haha, today we only have one car, it's okay.
Alice: only one
Shure:  感觉钱包又被掏空了一次是吧
Shure: Feels like my wallet got emptied again, huh?
Shure:  哎哪边是结账来着
Shure: Hey, where's the checkout?
Shure:  哦这呢
Shure: Oh, it's here.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 是不是少个人呢
Jake: Are we missing someone?
Jake: 哪了
Jake: Where are they?
Jake: 哦呵背景太绿了我看不出来
Jake: Oh, the background is too green, I couldn't see them.
Tasha: 因为这两个才200
Tasha: Because these two are only 200.
Tasha: 可要40块钱
Tasha: But it costs 40 yuan.
Tasha: 这个300克
Tasha: This is 300 grams.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Tasha: 那我还回去
Tasha: Then I'll put it back.
Jake: 您好谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Katrina:  那我们是会员不
Katrina: So, are we members?
Katrina:  我们买这么多东西了
Katrina: We've bought so many things.
Katrina:  可以送我们一袋金针菇吗呵
Katrina: Can we get a bag of enoki mushrooms for free? Haha.
Shure:  3个蛋吧先咱
Shure: Let's get 3 eggs first.
Lucia: 我再去拿个车过来
Lucia: I'll go get another cart.
Lucia: 然后我们扫完的可以放另一个车里
Lucia: Then we can put the scanned items in the other cart.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Alice: 看我有那个啥
Alice: Look, I have that thing.
其他人：会员录入失败
Others: Membership entry failed.
Alice: 把我家地址给倒了
Alice: They messed up my home address.
Jake: 我我我试试
Jake: Let me try.
Jake: 这那个用的什么码呀
Jake: What code are they using?
Shure:  盒马APP
Shure: Hema app.
Jake: 一定要盒马是吧
Jake: It has to be Hema, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Alice: 我有但是我
Alice: I have it, but...
Jake: 没有啥也没有
Jake: Nothing, there's nothing.
Alice: 现在可以关吗
Alice: Can I turn it off now?
Jake: 呃你你我有你要一定要关吗干嘛呢
Jake: Uh, do you really have to turn it off? What are you doing?
Tasha: 干嘛呢
Tasha: What are you doing?
Shure:  我们在付钱
Shure: We're paying.
Alice: 打不开
Alice: It won't open.
Jake: 那
Jake: So
Alice: 呀就把我家地址给你
Alice: I'll give you my home address
Shure:  可以APP扫下一个
Shure: You can scan the next one with the app
Jake: 好那请吧
Jake: Okay, please go ahead
Jake: 去吧就
Jake: Just go
Shure:  好吧那又靠你了
Shure: Alright, it's up to you again
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Jake: 但是券已经用完了是吧
Jake: But the coupons are used up, right?
Alice: 能不能买点
Alice: Can we buy some more?
Jake: 啊不用不用不用不用不用
Jake: Ah, no need, no need, no need
Katrina:  那你会员可以免费领吗
Katrina: So can you get it for free with your membership?
Jake: 一星币的事情用不着
Jake: It's just about one star coin, not necessary
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Haha
Jake: 一星币的券跟这个有什么关系吗
Jake: Does a one-star coin coupon have anything to do with this?
Lucia: 我刚刚点开看了一下
Lucia: I just opened and checked
Lucia: 我好像又掉线了
Lucia: I think I got disconnected again
Lucia: 就在你说完之后
Lucia: Just after you said that
Jake: 哦没关系
Jake: Oh, it's okay
Lucia: 我说我去检查一下
Lucia: I said I'd check it out
Jake: 你只要是亮着的就没关系
Jake: As long as it's on, it's fine
Lucia: 哦那就行
Lucia: Oh, that's good then
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Jake: 就是以防万一吧
Jake: Just in case
Lucia: 他有时候会莫名其妙的掉线我觉得
Lucia: Sometimes it disconnects for no reason, I think
Jake: 对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Tasha: 看看能不能买个这个
Tasha: See if you can buy this
Shure:  你试试吧
Shure: Give it a try
Katrina:  对那个了吗
Katrina: Did it work?
其他人：点击屏幕右下方按钮进行支付
Others: Click the button on the bottom right of the screen to pay
Katrina:  到时候我们弄完了就往那边移
Katrina: We'll move it over there once we're done
Alice: 肉放一块吧
Alice: Put the meat together
Shure:  我快转晕了
Shure: I'm getting dizzy from fast-forwarding
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Alice: 还有肉没
Alice: Is there any more meat?
Lucia: 放不下的话就放这袋子里
Lucia: If it doesn't fit, put it in this bag
Jake:袋子哪领的呀
Jake: Where did you get the bag?
Alice: 买的
Alice: Bought it
Jake: 哦买的呀哦
Jake: Oh, you bought it?
Shure:  3个袋 4个袋子一新币差不多
Shure: 3 bags, 4 bags, about one dollar each.
Jake: 这么贵
Jake: That's so expensive.
Lucia: 这袋子这么贵哇
Lucia: These bags are so expensive!
Jake: 一箱亿新币啊
Jake: A whole box costs a dollar each?
Lucia: 现在国内的袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: Even bags in our country are this expensive now.
Jake: 这一块多钱
Jake: This one is so expensive.
Alice: 并且他现在你外送的话必须买袋子
Alice: Plus, if you want delivery, you have to buy a bag now.
Jake: 这一块多钱一个袋子是吗我去
Jake: So each bag costs more than a dollar? Oh my!
Shure:  一块5一个
Shure: One dollar fifty each.
Shure:  哎又给你换到6了哈哈哈
Shure: Oh, they changed it to six dollars now, haha.
Lucia: 哎不过其实到哈哈哈
Lucia: Actually, to be honest, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Lucia: 不过其实到处袋子都收钱
Lucia: But honestly, they charge for bags everywhere.
Lucia: 不过我没想到
Lucia: But I didn't expect...
Lucia: 国内现在袋子也这么贵了
Lucia: Even bags in our country are this expensive now.
Alice: 把那个调料
Alice: Pass the seasoning.
Shure:  这个弄了吧
Shure: Let's do this one.
Shure:  就只有这个没动了是吧
Shure: This is the only one left, right?
Shure:  这个
Shure: This one.
Shure:  你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure:  你好你好
Shure: Hi, hi.
Jake: 啥时候买的哦Max
Jake: When did you buy it, Max?
Lucia: 啊那这个要不放这袋子里
Lucia: Oh, should we put this in the bag?
Tasha: 我们昨天家今天买起来
Tasha: We bought it yesterday, today we start using it.
Tasha: 帮我开张卡的钱都可以省下来了
Tasha: I can save the money from opening a new card.
Tasha: 开打之后打8.8折
Tasha: After opening, there's an 8.8% discount.
Jake: 好吧那应该开什么还是什么呀
Jake: Alright, so should we open it or what?
Tasha: 应该第一天就开
Tasha: We should have opened it on the first day.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 卡多少钱
Jake: How much is the card?
Tasha: 只要298 跟加入土门是一个价
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 258 好吧
Tasha: 258, alright.
Tasha: 他还比我便宜点
Tasha: It's even cheaper than me.
Shure:  好来来来
Shure: Alright, come on.
Lucia: 这个放到这边
Lucia: Put this over here.
Lucia: 然后这个放在这行吗
Lucia: And put this here, okay?
Tasha: 付钱了吗已经
Tasha: Have you paid already?
Alice: 那个男人吗
Alice: That guy?
Jake: 护弹使者
Jake: Bulletproof guard.
Shure:  这个又得端着了是吗
Shure: Do we have to hold this again?
Jake: 护蛋使者
Lucia: 我端着吧
Lucia: I'll hold it.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  护蛋
Shure: Guard the eggs.
Lucia: 咱们是不是还有个饮料没放到这里面
Lucia: Did we forget to put a drink in here?
Jake: 那个还有是吗
Jake: There's still one left, right?
Alice: 那你喝的你拿着还是给你放着
Alice: Do you want to hold the drink or should I put it down for you?
Lucia: 这个能能放下吗
Lucia: Can this fit here?
Lucia: 放不下我就拿着好了
Lucia: If it doesn't fit, I'll just hold it.
Shure:  但还是
Shure: But still...
Shure:  手拿吧哦
Shure: Just hold it.
Shure:  还没到那
Shure: It's not there yet.
Lucia: 这么鸡蛋可以和这个放一起对吧
Lucia: Can the eggs and this be put together?
Tasha: 先放这吧要不要
Tasha: Do you want to put it here first?
Lucia: 也行可以都先放到车里
Lucia: Sure, we can put everything in the car first.
Lucia: 然后一会提的时候再拿出来
Lucia: And then take it out when we need it.
Katrina:  go go go
Katrina: Go go go!
Shure:  哦没买百事可乐我靠
Shure: Oh, we didn't buy Pepsi. Damn.
Alice: 盒马大采购
Alice: Big shopping spree at Hema.
Jake: 为什么要百事可乐
Jake: Why do we need Pepsi?
Shure:  因为腌东西的那个百事会更甜一点
Shure: Because Pepsi is a bit sweeter for marinating.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  可口反正它就不好喝
Shure: Coke just doesn't taste good.
Jake: 好这能推到哪
Jake: Alright, where can we push this?
Shure:  对呀好像也就这
Shure: Yeah, it seems like that's it.
Lucia: 他不拦着咱咱就往外推哈哈哈
Lucia: If he doesn't block us, we'll just push it out, haha.
Jake: 行
Jake: Sure.
Shure:  但也上不去啊主要是
Shure: But we can't get it up, that's the main problem.
Jake: 挡着挡着挡着挡着挡着挡着
Jake: Block it, block it, block it, block it.
Jake: 失败大失败
Jake: Fail, big fail.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Shure:  那要要不你护蛋吧
Shure: Then, how about you guard the eggs?
其他人：人多力量大 一人一个就完了
Others: Strength in numbers, one person for each.
Jake: 对分不到都
Jake: Yeah, there won't be enough for everyone.
Lucia: 你这个任务艰巨
Lucia: Your task is tough.
Lucia: 一定要保护好他哈哈
Lucia: You must protect it well, haha.
Alice: 谁把我的蛋撞碎了我就把谁撞死
Alice: If anyone breaks my egg, I'll break them.
Lucia: 哈哈哈好可怕
Lucia: Hahaha, that's scary.
Alice: 确实我们封批是这样的
Alice: Yeah, that's how we roll.
Lucia: 每天被撞的现代人
Lucia: Modern people getting hit every day.
Lucia: 不我的精神状态不良好
Lucia: No, my mental state isn't good.
Lucia: 啊会
Lucia: Ah, it happens.
Lucia: 但大部分时候我都只是一只舒懒
Lucia: But most of the time, I'm just lazy.
Alice: 哈哈哈呆呆的反应慢慢的那种吗
Alice: Hahaha, like slow reactions and all that?
Lucia: 嗯我的
Lucia: Yeah, my...
Lucia: 我精神上想成为一只树啦
Lucia: Mentally, I want to be a tree.
Lucia: 但是很可惜我还是一只人类
Lucia: But unfortunately, I'm still a human.
Alice: 你会
Alice: You will...
Alice: 逼着自己快
Alice: Push yourself to be fast.
Lucia: 对对就是为了融入人类社会
Lucia: Yeah, to fit into human society.
Lucia: 我不得不把自己伪装的像人类一样
Lucia: I have to disguise myself as a human.
Shure:  爬上去才对
Shure: You need to climb up.
Lucia: 哈哈哈微微露出一个轻蔑的笑容
Lucia: Hahaha, showing a slight contemptuous smile.
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Tasha: 上楼干嘛
Tasha: Why are we going upstairs?
Jake: 上楼出去
Jake: Going upstairs to go out.
Jake: 出去我们在楼底下好像对
Jake: We need to go out, we're downstairs.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 啊是吗
Tasha: Oh, really?
Tasha: 算算
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 影创优品
Tasha: Yingchuang Products.
Tasha: 走多少步了
Tasha: How many steps have we taken?
Jake: 很多步
Jake: A lot of steps.
Tasha: 你脚疼不疼
Tasha: Are your feet hurting?
Jake: 还还还挺疼的
Jake: Yeah, they hurt quite a bit.
Jake: 这拖鞋确实不适合走路
Jake: These slippers aren't good for walking.
Jake: 还得是用我的新加坡的拖鞋
Jake: I should've used my slippers from Singapore.
Tasha: 那个拖鞋走路就不不痛
Tasha: Those slippers don't hurt to walk in?
Jake: 这这底稍微厚一点
Jake: These have a slightly thicker sole.
Tasha: 我勒个抖
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: 才走8,000步
Tasha: Only 8,000 steps?
Tasha: 真毒假毒啊
Tasha: Is this real or fake?
Alice: 打车吧
Alice: Let's take a cab.
Jake: 哎你还亮吗
Jake: Hey, are you still on?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Lucia: 哎这是一个扭蛋机吗
Lucia: Hey, is this a gashapon machine?
Alice: 亮着呢
Alice: It's still bright.
Jake: 亮确实
Jake: Bright indeed.
Tasha: 这个能扭出啥来吗
Tasha: Can this twist out anything?
Lucia: 好了我也是
Lucia: Alright, me too.
Lucia: 竟然扭不出来
Lucia: Can't twist it out after all.
Alice: 在干嘛
Alice: What are you doing?
Shure:  们6个人正好打一个商务
Shure: Six of us, just right for a business ride.
Alice: 这次还没弄好吧
Alice: Haven't got it done yet, right?
Jake: 对打个商务好
Jake: Yeah, a business ride is good.
Jake: 就在这等着吧
Jake: Let's just wait here.
Jake: 哎这边我看一下在哪打车哈
Jake: Hey, let me check where to get a car here.
Shure:  应该这就行
Shure: Should be fine here.
Shure:  那能停公交就能那啥
Shure: If a bus can stop here, then it's good.
Jake: 在这在喜茶那合个影吧要不
Jake: Let's take a photo at HeyTea, shall we?
Jake: 就是或者就在这个地方也很
Jake: Or we can do it here, it's pretty cool too.
Jake: 也很酷炫
Jake: It's quite cool here.
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This place.
Lucia: 要扫一下喜茶吗
Lucia: Should we scan HeyTea?
Jake: 我先打车
Jake: I'll get a car first.
Shure:  没开吧那个
Shure: That place isn't open, right?
Tasha: 应该在门外开了吧
Tasha: It should be open outside.
Lucia: 哈哈打哈欠会传染
Lucia: Haha, yawning is contagious.
Jake: 那边那头去
Jake: Let's head over there.
Shure:  出门左拐
Shure: Turn left when you exit.
Jake: 看一下有更好的地方吗
Jake: Let's see if there's a better spot.
Shure:  门口不能停
Shure: Can't stop at the entrance.
Jake: 还是还是这吧行吧
Jake: Alright, let's just stay here then.
Jake: 哎啥玩意
Jake: Hey, what's that thing?
Alice: 这个洞特别像一个怪笑的
Alice: This hole looks like a creepy smile.
Alice: 眼睛一个怪笑的东西
Alice: An eye, a creepy smiling thing.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 这吧行吧
Jake: Here is fine.
Jake: 这好
Jake: This is good.
Shure:  对吧
Shure: Right?
Alice: 两个大蝴蝶眼
Alice: Two big butterfly eyes.
Shure:  这就行
Shure: This works.
Shure:  OK这这可以可以OK就是
Shure: OK, this is fine, this is OK.
Jake: 行好
Jake: Alright, good.
Alice: 你不掉了
Alice: You're not falling.
Tasha: 累了
Tasha: Tired.
Lucia: 加1
Lucia: +1
Jake: 什么 10086 好的
Jake: What? 10086, okay.
Alice: 10086
Lucia: 哈哈哈 10036
Lucia: Hahaha, 10036.
Alice: 世上世上无难事
Alice: There's no difficulty in the world.
Alice: 只要肯乐
Alice: As long as you're willing to try.
Alice: 只要肯乐欢
Alice: As long as you're willing to try happily.
Alice: 什么意思
Alice: What does that mean?
Lucia: 世上无难事
Lucia: There’s no difficulty in the world.
Lucia: 只要肯乐观
Lucia: As long as you stay optimistic.
Alice: 好乐观我看成乐欢了
Alice: Oh, optimistic! I read it as happy.
Alice: 啊乐观啊
Alice: Ah, optimistic!
Alice: 乐观乐观
Alice: Optimistic, optimistic.
Alice: 我说嘛乐观是个什么东西
Alice: I was wondering, what does "happy" mean?
Lucia: 你如生活的
Lucia: You live your life...
Alice: 哇哇大爷你没事吧
Alice: Wow, wow, are you okay, sir?
Lucia: 热爱什么鬼鬼
Lucia: What kind of love is this?
Jake: 还有11分钟才到
Jake: There are still 11 minutes left.
Jake: 所以放地上吧
Jake: So just put it on the ground.
Shure:  先放一会吧
Shure: Let's leave it for a while.
Jake: 就放这吧
Jake: Just leave it here.
Shure:  （歌词）我在无言的夜
Shure: (Lyrics) I'm in the silent night...
Shure:  洋葱买的吧
Shure: You bought onions, right?
Alice: 买了
Alice: Yes, I bought them.
Lucia: 好好吧
Lucia: Okay, fine.
Lucia: 你对生活的热爱
Lucia: Your love for life...
Lucia: sorry看错了
Lucia: Sorry, I misread.
Jake: 这样可以拍吧
Jake: Can we film like this?
Jake: 这样可以拍吗
Shure:  什么奇怪的事情
Shure: What a strange thing.
Lucia: 你醒了
Lucia: You're awake.
Jake: 你醒了哈哈哈哈哈妙啊
Jake: You're awake, hahaha, wonderful!
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha!
Alice: 啊哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ahahaha!
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha!
Jake: 好就这样吧
Jake: Alright, let’s leave it at that.
Shure:  来我们叫醒一下AI
Shure: Let's wake up the AI.
Jake: 就这样挺好
Jake: It's good like this.
Jake: 来来来叫醒叫醒一下
Jake: Come on, wake up, wake up.
Jake: 叫醒服务
Jake: Wake-up service.
Katrina:  到底谁啊
Katrina: Who on earth is it?
Lucia: 呃他的手机
Lucia: Uh, his phone...
Shure:  咱们一个一个露出来吧
Shure: Let's reveal them one by one.
Shure:  咱们先拍一张
Shure: Let's take a photo first.
Shure:  然后拍个视频
Shure: Then record a video.
Katrina:  1234还差一个人呢
Katrina: 1, 2, 3, 4... We're missing one person.
Jake: 好等一下
Jake: Okay, hold on a sec.
Lucia: 要合个影
Lucia: We need to take a group photo.
Shure:  喝牛奶喝的
Shure: Drinking milk...
Shure:  有一人没露出来快快快
Shure: Someone isn't in the shot, hurry up!
Jake: 快快快
Jake: Hurry, hurry!
Jake: 晚了再来一次
Jake: Too late, let's do it again.
Lucia: 没戴眼镜
Lucia: I'm not wearing glasses.
Shure:  而且你没戴眼镜
Shure: And you're not wearing glasses.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You're awake.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You're awake.
Shure:  那已经是2077年了
Shure: It's already the year 2077.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 等会我把这个带上忘了
Jake: Wait, I forgot to take this.
Shure:  Wifi没带上
Shure: Didn't bring the Wifi.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈没
Jake: Hahahahahaha, no.
Shure:  哈哈哈接收不着信号了
Shure: Hahaha, can't get a signal now.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Alice: 我来了我来了
Alice: I'm here, I'm here.
Lucia: 马上收不到信号了
Lucia: About to lose signal.
Shure:  是吗让自己看的像个活人一样
Shure: Really? Make yourself look alive.
Alice: 反了呢啊
Alice: It's upside down.
Alice: 没有
Alice: No, it's not.
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 有点歪呃没关系歪对啊
Jake: It's a bit crooked, but it's fine. Crooked is good.
Alice: 有点歪说实话
Alice: It's a bit crooked, honestly.
Lucia: 哈哈搅动转场
Lucia: Haha, mix it up.
Jake: 好再来
Jake: Alright, let's do it again.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  非常帅
Shure: Very cool.
Jake: 这次很好
Jake: This time was great.
Jake: 那视频一个一个出
Jake: Let's roll out the videos one by one.
Jake: 一个一个进来
Jake: Bring them in one by one.
Jake: 然后你醒了
Jake: Then you woke up.
Jake: 你醒了你醒了
Jake: You woke up, you woke up.
Katrina:  要说这句话是吗
Katrina: You want me to say this?
Jake: 呵要吗
Jake: Haha, do you want to?
Jake: 可以要
Jake: You can if you want.
Shure:  好快快先撤出来
Shure: Okay, quickly, let's pull out.
Alice: 来呀谁呀
Alice: Come on, who is it?
Shure:  从杨老板开始
Shure: Starting with Jake.
Alice: 你醒了
Alice: You're awake.
Jake: 进来就呆着
Jake: Just stay in when you come in.
Jake: 重来重来重来
Jake: Again, again, again.
Shure:  哎重来没有默契没有啊
Shure: Ugh, again, there's no coordination at all.
Tasha: 什么你醒了
Tasha: What, you're awake?
Alice: 你醒了
Alice: You're awake.
Jake: 来来来闪开
Jake: Come on, make way.
Lucia: 那个表情包
Lucia: That meme...
Tasha: 哦哦醒了
Tasha: Oh, oh, awake.
Lucia: 你醒了快起来做作业哈哈
Lucia: You're awake, get up and do your homework, haha.
Jake: 你醒了
Jake: You're awake.
Alice: 你醒了
Alice: You're awake.
Lucia: 你醒了
Lucia: You're awake.
Tasha: 醒了
Tasha: Awake.
Katrina:  你醒了
Katrina: You're awake.
Shure:  你醒了
Shure: You're awake.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  你醒了吗
Shure: Are you awake?
Jake: 2077啊哈哈哈哈哈哈傻屌
Jake: 2077, hahaha, you idiot.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahahahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈卧槽
Katrina: Hahaha, damn it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈我靠哈
Tasha: Hahaha, oh my god, haha.
Lucia: 我靠哈
Lucia: Oh my god, haha.
Katrina:  这是噩梦你知道吗这噩
Katrina: This is a nightmare, you know? This night...
Tasha: 哈好
Tasha: Haha, okay.
Lucia: 哈哈瞬间变恐怖片
Lucia: Haha, it's instantly a horror movie.
Jake: 我靠很难
Jake: Oh my god, it's hard.
Jake: 哈哈哈直接晕倒
Jake: Hahaha, just faint.
Alice: 你不要过来呀
Alice: Don't come over here.
Tasha: 不要过来呀
Tasha: Don't come over here.
Lucia: 你不要过来呀你不要过来
Lucia: Don't come over here, don't come over.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈根本醒不了
Jake: Hahaha, can't wake up at all.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Shure:  别鬼压床了
Shure: Don't let the ghost press you down
Jake: ha ha
Jake: Ha ha
Shure:  捡到了
Shure: Found it
Jake: 看一眼车
Jake: Take a look at the car
Jake: 还有8分钟
Jake: 8 minutes left
Jake: 还能再整点活
Jake: We can still do some more work
Lucia: 想看一眼那个视频
Lucia: I want to see that video
Jake: 好好好
Jake: Alright, alright
Jake: 好慢啊
Jake: So slow
Lucia: 新物种生
Lucia: A new species was born
Jake: 傻吊
Jake: Idiot
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Alice: 有鬼
Alice: There's a ghost
Jake: 新物种生活确实
Jake: New species life, indeed
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahahaha
Alice: 有脏东西哈哈
Alice: There's something dirty, haha
Shure:  我靠新物种生活
Shure: Damn, new species life
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Shure:  上面这字还很应景
Shure: The words above are quite fitting
Jake: 可以这个
Jake: This is good
Jake: 个最后一天的开场视频都有了
Jake: We even have the opening video for the last day
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  你醒吧然后就大家就都退出去了
Shure: You wake up, and then everyone just leaves
Shure:  我那个叫什么10秒点出率
Shure: I call it the 10-second click rate
Shure:  对哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, haha
Shure:  就卡在我那10秒了
Shure: It just stuck on my 10 seconds
Jake: 丰收歌曲
Jake: Harvest song
Shure:  好好好
Shure: Alright, alright
Tasha: 是星期日还是星期一呀
Tasha: Is it Sunday or Monday?
Jake: 星期日
Jake: Sunday
Tasha: 星期日
Tasha: Sunday
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Alice: 快递快递
Alice: Delivery, delivery
Shure:  （歌词）自由经过了山
Shure: (Lyrics) Freedom passed through the mountains
Shure:  （歌词）我想开着我的烂摩托转一转
Shure: (Lyrics) I want to ride my broken motorbike around
Shure:  （歌词）可惜我的心
Shure: (Lyrics) But unfortunately my heart
Shure:  （歌词）我可惜我把车卖了
Shure: (Lyrics) I regret selling my car
Shure:  （歌词）我的心呀我的心
Shure: (Lyrics) My heart, my heart
Shure:  （歌词）变成了处处处处都给你
Shure: (Lyrics) Has turned into giving you everything
Alice: 还有半个小时能录
Alice: We can record for another half hour
Jake: 没问题
Jake: No problem
Jake: 就上车就关掉
Jake: Just get in the car and turn it off
Lucia: 当前网络不稳定
Lucia: The network is unstable right now
Shure:  （歌词）躲在屋檐的
Shure: (Lyrics) Hiding under the eaves
Shure:  少喝点奶吧可
Shure: Drink less milk, okay
Jake: 这地挺酷
Jake: This place is pretty cool
Shure:  刷哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure:  啊你在拍照啊
Shure: Ah, you're taking pictures
Jake: 等会等会等会你你你
Jake: Wait wait wait, you you you
Shure:  你浪费我的表情了
Shure: You're wasting my expressions
Jake: 你从后面绕过来吧
Jake: Come around from the back
Jake: 要不就我
Jake: Or I can...
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Jake: 我开始我开始录了
Jake: I'll start, I'll start recording
Jake: 哼沙雕
Jake: Humph, silly
Jake: 靠是
Jake: Damn, it's...
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good
Shure:  到了吗车看眼
Shure: Are we there yet? Look at the car
Shure:  车看眼车
Shure: Look at the car, the car
Jake: 还有5分钟
Jake: Five more minutes
Jake: 出去等着吧
Jake: Go wait outside
Shure:  咱们要控制变量
Shure: We need to control the variables
Shure:  比如说你现在不喝牛奶了
Shure: For example, you stop drinking milk now
Jake: 走吧出去吧
Jake: Let's go, head out
Shure:  （歌词）起来饥寒交迫的人
Shure: (Lyrics) Rise, you who are starving and cold
Shure:  （歌词）在全世界
Shure: (Lyrics) All over the world
Tasha: 最帅的人会领两个好
Tasha: The most handsome person will get two good ones
Shure:  杨老板哈哈哈
Shure: Jake, hahaha
Jake: 你哈哈
Jake: You, hahaha
Jake: 你最帅不用不用不用一一一
Jake: You're the most handsome, no no no no
Shure:  杨老板哎
Shure: Jake, hey
Shure:  别客气哎呀呀呀呀
Shure: Don't be modest, oh yeah yeah yeah
Jake: 呃呃呃这么客气
Jake: Uh uh uh, so polite
Shure:  行吧那就给你吧
Shure: Alright, I'll give it to you then
Jake: 蛋呢蛋在蛋在
Jake: The egg, where's the egg, where's the egg
Shure:  护好蛋
Shure: Protect the egg
Jake: 蛋在哪啊
Jake: Where are the eggs?
Shure:  蛋护好蛋
Shure: Protect the eggs.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 所以最终没有最帅的人
Tasha: So, in the end, there's no most handsome person.
Shure:  你在反复欣赏那个视频
Shure: You're repeatedly watching that video.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 没有最帅的人
Jake: No most handsome person.
Alice: 你没有反复吧哈哈
Alice: You're not watching it repeatedly, haha.
Jake:这是哪啊
Jake: Where is this place?
Jake: 走上道路口
Jake: Walk up to the road intersection.
Jake: 这过得去吧
Jake: Can we get through here?
Tasha: 那当然是翻山越岭
Tasha: Of course, we have to climb over mountains.
Shure:  他到哪了
Shure: Where is he?
Shure:  我看一眼
Shure: Let me take a look.
Jake: 三分钟
Jake: Three minutes.
Shure:  就在咱们面前是吧
Shure: He’s right in front of us, right?
Shure:  那咱们从那绕一下吧走吧
Shure: Let's just go around from there, come on.
Jake: 啊他
Jake: Ah, he...
Jake: 他说可以开进来
Jake: He said he can drive in.
Shure:  不这是非机动车道
Shure: No, this is a non-motorized lane.
Shure:  他进不来的
Shure: He can't drive in.
Tasha: 他可以看到外面那个吧
Tasha: He can see the outside, right?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  不是但是咱们也过不去啊
Shure: No, but we can't get through either.
Tasha: 过了去吧
Tasha: We can get through.
Shure:  他很窄真的很窄
Shure: It's very narrow, really narrow.
Jake: 走试试
Jake: Let's try walking.
Jake: 那要不怎么照
Jake: How do we take a photo then?
Tasha: 哎你小心摄像头
Tasha: Hey, watch the camera.
Jake: 这个
Jake: This one?
Tasha: 我是说钻的时候
Tasha: I mean when you're squeezing through.
Shure:  钻的是吧
Shure: Squeezing through, right?
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Shure:  要钻过去是吧
Shure: You have to squeeze through, right?
Jake: 哎从旁边不能过吗
Jake: Hey, can't we go from the side?
Shure:  旁边
Shure: The side?
Tasha: 可以呀
Tasha: Yeah, we can.
Shure:  真费劲吧
Shure: It's really a hassle, right?
Shure:  杨老板你你你你能吗
Shure: Jake, can you, you, you do it?
Jake: 哈哈哈我有可能的吧
Jake: Hahaha, it's possible for me, right?
Jake: 选一个好道
Jake: Pick a good one.
Shure:  337是吗
Shure: Is it 337?
Jake: 776
Jake: 776.
Tasha: 那就是
Tasha: That means...
Tasha: 是这辆吗好吧
Tasha: Is it this one? Okay.
Tasha: 这辆吗
Tasha: This one?
Jake: 棕色别克
Jake: Brown Buick.
Jake: 776
Jake: 776.
Jake: 那个像吗
Jake: Does that look like it?
Jake: 那车后轮
Jake: That car's rear wheel.
Shure:  776 对没错
Shure: 776, right, no mistake.
Jake: 就是他
Jake: That's the one.
Jake: 太对了
Jake: Absolutely right.
Tasha: 都是打领带的
Tasha: They're all wearing ties.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  要放后备箱吗
Katrina: Should we put it in the trunk?
Shure:  啊尾号7008是吧
Shure: Ah, the last digits are 7008, right?
Jake: 对对可对了
Jake: Yeah, that's right.
Lucia: 啊没有啊没有
Lucia: Ah, no, no.
Alice: 没有没有
Alice: No, no.
Jake: 没箱子
Jake: No trunk.
Jake: 呀再次保安位
Jake: Ah, back to security.
Jake: 关吧
Jake: Close it.
Lucia: 理论上说是不是我
Lucia: Theoretically, shouldn't it be me?
Lucia: 应该是保安
Lucia: Should be security.
Lucia: 然后我下去刚好给你们一开门
Lucia: Then I could come down to open the door for you.
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure:  没有把它录了放冰箱里吧
Shure: No, record it and put it in the fridge.
Jake: 下车开始录
Jake: 放到冰箱就给我导
Jake: Put it in the fridge and send it to me.
Jake: 对对对就停掉停掉
Jake: Yeah, yeah, just stop it, stop it.
Jake: 这一路啥也不是
Jake: This whole trip is pointless.
Jake: 我录完放冰箱